à
l'évidence volts il a
presque prête
elle descend l'escalier pour qu'elle
fasse gaffe à la dernière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis restée une brochette julia
roberts a fait moins chier way j'attends
que vous hein
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous me concerne pas
je vous demande de vous arrêter
franchement c'est la faute du taxi je te
jure toi tu pourrais danser toi même et
non parce qu'on danse dans cette
émission mais on a arditi qui s'est
blessé au pied et on a d'un fils qui
s'est blessé on a eu des blessés le ski
c'est une connerie c'est six mois ouais
c'est vrai la raison lors du drame les
pantalons rouges il faudrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez le plateau là rien plateau
extra lourd là sur quatre invités il ya
trois humoristes c'est vendredi tout est
permis comment un juge je glisse un
petit message parce qu'on vous connais
vous les humoristes voilà quand c'est
pas ou qui fait des blagues ça rigole
jamais donc florence vous avez fait des
chroniques chez ruquier kamel dans le
grand journal guillermo sur france inter
je vous préviens si y'en a qui rigole
pas je redis fut sapir chronique
à on est sympa on fait des blagues
machin on est rigolo c'est les pires
thierry alors que au moins regarder avec
arditi on n'est pas déçu voilà ça c'est
leur
importance
bon j'ai commencé par évidemment la
patronne la taulière pierre arditi
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
pierre qui au théâtre de l'atelier avec
la pièce le cas sneijder voilà c'est
l'histoire d'un homme victime d'un
terrible accident d'ascenseur et qui
sort du coma totalement transformé
petite comédie petite comédie vous
pensez que c'est une pièce qui peut
toucher tout le monde même les gens qui
habitent en rez de chaussée ou en
famille on perd ou comment ça se passe
non mais dans la pièce vous jouez un
jeune homme de 60 ans ouais quand 72-66
un jeune homme bah ouais non mais je
suis désolé il ya un méchant mais les
faits sont là je suis têtu mais toi
aussi tu continues à être moqué des
vieux oh non non non assassinés kerry
chérie c'est un fait quand tu es plus
proche de brigitte que des manuels
macron bon bah voilà
alors pierre dans la pièce vous vous
travaillez au retrait approvisionnement
de la société des alcools du québec là
pour françois vous avez joué aussi dans
un monologue dans le sang de la vigne
quand ça se passe ce petit souci
d'alcoolémie pierre
d'ailleurs vous avez une cave et non
vous avez combien de bout de quinze
mille 15 mille c'est vrai j'en ai moi
maintenant j'en ai je m'en fiche c'est
ça la gauche quinze mille mais attends
tu peux être de gauche oui c'est ça la
gauche que je suis la nouvelle laguna
berline en a que cinq mille lui oui et
c'est du vin de soif
je précise quinze mille bouteilles
pleines évidemment ouais vide sinon
c'est chez johnny dans sa note
alors pierre grand comédien évidemment
et puis vous avez fait beaucoup de
doublage vous avez doublé superman
christopher walken terence hill dustin
hoffman et sa meilleure voie a été celle
qu'il a donnée à hollande en 2012
attention parce que pierre il s'était
élevé contre le holland bashing et oui
on arrête faut qu'on arrête de taper sur
françois hollande il lui reste deux mois
oui c'est un peu comme une sorte de
phase terminale voilà faut l'accompagner
il appartient et il a fait des choses
très bien ces derniers temps rien de
cette semaine je vous jure que c'est
vrai il a proposé à donald trump de
venir à disneyland paris pour découvrir
ce qu'était la france mais aussi si
c'est le meilleur aperçu de la france
regardez par exemple le train de la mine
où tu attends deux heures c'est la grève
de la sncf
avec les tasses c'est comme le métro
parisien est arrivé avec le souriant
nature sort avec une petite envie de
vomir et puis les migrants basse et
pirates des caraïbes tout simplement
voilà c'est
[Applaudissements]
notre deuxième à l'itc monsieur
guillermo but ici
alors après les chanteurs les pédophiles
aujourd'hui les belges nous envoient
leurs humoriste c'est sa grand-mère tous
et belge qui vient de voler le pain des
français
payent moins d'impôts il ya moins de
boulot c'est
non mais le taquine parce que guillermo
olaso camarades de jeu sur france inter
on c'est vrai on est dans la bande
originale de nagui tous les lundis
mardis mercredis jeudis vendredis de 11h
à 12h30 après je veux pas faire de
prendre particulière mais non charline
van snick heures et alex vizorek iggy
remobiliser kérébel ac devenu belge
interne mais c'est à la cantine ses
moules frites ils ont remplacé les
machines à café par des tireuses à bière
c'est l'enfer
[Applaudissements]
doute bien d'autres spectacles guillermo
guiz idiot au point virgule il ya plein
de sujets il ya le terrorisme le viol la
zoophilie la drogue les handicapés la
pédophilie donc y'a que des blagues sur
les belges
et cause en importe ce qu'on peut tiens
on donne on vient et voilà un portage
c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
notre troisième invité pour 25% des
français qui veulent voter pour une
femme qui ressemble à son père avec une
perruque blonde un arabe qui fait
disparaître des choses ça s'appelle un
voleur dans son cas c'est de la magie
c'est monsieur km le medad
cannell kamel le magicien a acquis et
café danse avec les stars d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas très longtemps on peut
s'arrêter dessus en seconde ce qu'il a
perdu face à julien lepers
au trivial pursuit je veux bien mais pas
à danse avec les stars je sais pas si tu
as eu julien lepers d'anciens on leur
dit qu'il faisait une crise d'épilepsie
ou alors ou alors qu'il avait qu'il
avait caché un sex toys et qu'il avait
perdu la télécommande mais
[Applaudissements]
jamais le magicien qui revient sur scène
à bobino voilà et je crois qu'après
avoir fait danse avec les stars a décidé
d'intégrer de la danse at on simplement
besoin de ta pa fé top chef du coup
vous dites qu'en france on a une image
un peu ringard de la magie moi je suis
pas d'accord parce que j'ai juste qu'on
manque d'ambition mais regardez par
exemple patrick balkany by réussissait à
faire disparaître des maisons de son
patrimoine immobilier
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est de la grande région parce que 5
et de la concurrence au niveau des
magiciens le but c'est toujours d'aller
plus haut d'impressionner encore plus ça
commence avec david copperfield qui a
fait disparaître la statue de la liberté
après you ben laden qui a fait
disparaître le world trade center mais
ça met la pression en quoi un peu et ça
mais surtout une mauvaise ambiance on
termine avec la patronne mesdames et
messieurs c'est mademoiselle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non ce plan ce foresti qui vient pour
son dernier film qui s'appelle deux plus
belles florence ou une femme qui sort
d'un cancer du sein et qui essaie de
retrouver une vie normale
pierre arditi re bonsoir
nom alors je préfère retenir c'est pas
une comédie et d'ailleurs je vous
préviens thiery il est hors de question
que j'entende une seule fois que deux
plus belles c'est le tchao pantin de
florence foresti away florence foresti
est une comédienne un point c'est tout
est ce que quand guillaume canet fait
rock'n'roll on lui dit c'est sont les
loups la cuisse je ne crois pas laissez
la tranquille
[Applaudissements]
c'est un rôle qui était formidable qu'un
roulement on peut lire un petit peu à
contre emploi parce qu'à rouler ils vont
à un humoriste c'est qu'on a endossé un
rôle grave un rôle à contre emploi pour
pénélope fillon va ce serait de jouer
une assistante parlementaire par
bien côté de vous il ya mathieu
kassovitz qui est formidable aussi il
serait très bien il parle pas du 11
septembre il est extraordinaire et non
il n'a pas essayé de vous convaincre que
les illuminati avec cris le cancer pour
tuer le lobby des puissances financières
américaines ça sent le très beau succès
vraiment toute façon si c'est pas le cas
kassovitz dira que c'était une
conspiration des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
en tout cas dans le film pour vous en
sortir il ya nicole garcia qui joue une
prof de danse et qui essaie de vous
apprendre à être une vraie femme au
mentor ouais ouais d'apprentissage
d'être une femme du vous a montré une
photo d'un mandat lire du coup
mais si
conscient
difficile à gérer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux